Just a Rebuilder. Rebuilder is that unit, that little electrical unit that helps with neuropathy.
I purchased a Rebuilder to address neuropathy from Kibo. On your website you tell those who
purchased the item to buy a divided container to use with a Rebuilder. Yes, one of those
little divided buckets that you'd get at Walmart that you'd carry your cleaning supplies around with,
or your gardening supplies around with. It's like a bucket on each side of the handle in the middle.
So I did that. I read the complete directions to the Rebuilder and it says nothing about using a
divided container. So I'm confused what's the purpose of needing that. So I don't know why
the Rebuilder doesn't have that data, but you have to use a divided container fill both sides up with
water. Use the rubberized leads. Connect that to the lead itself, the little rubber pads. You drop
the rubber pads in each side of the water, put your feet in there, and then you turn the thing up
and tell your comfort level is comfortable. And any 15 to 30 minutes is recommended. Typically they've
done studies on it. Even though I think they recommend 30 minutes per session, 90% of the treatment is
done in the first 15 minutes so it depends on what your time frame is.